what we want to do in this video is
figure out what 438 minus
272 is and to help us think about that
we have these place value blocks right
over here and so you can see 438 we have
four hundreds 100 200 300 400 we have
three tens
one two three
and then we have eight ones you can
count those eight ones right over there
and from that we're going to take away
two hundreds so that's 200 right over
there
seven tens or 70 right over here and two
ones so pause this video and see if you
can figure out what this is going to be
all right now let's work through this
together
so first of all we could start in the
ones place and we can see we have eight
ones and then we're going to take away
two ones so that's pretty
straightforward we're just going to be
left with
six ones right over here
now let's go to the tens place now the
tens place is interesting we have three
tens here and we're trying to take away
from that one two three four five six
seven tens so how do you take seven tens
from three tens
well
luckily we can regroup from the hundreds
place
what if we were to take
this piece
right over here from the hundreds to the
tenths place and now this is going to be
the equivalent of ten tens so let me
represent it
that way once again i took a hundreds
that's the same thing as one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten tens
well this is useful now because now i
have ten plus three tens or you could
say i have thirteen tens and now i can
take away seven tens from that so let's
do that
let's take away one
two
three four five six seven and what we
are left with is
six tens right over here
so now i have
six tens left six ones left and then the
hundreds i have three hundreds i'm going
to take away two of them so i'm going to
take away
100 and 200 so i'm left with just 100
there so i'm left with 100
6 tens and 6 ones so this is one hundred
six tens and six ones or one hundred and
sixty six